.
HARMEET, RUNNING FOR CHAIR IN
WASHINGTON THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: REPUBLICANS SET UP A
NEW COMMITTEE MODELLED AFTER THE
CHURCH COMMITTEE PLAYING
DECISIVE ROLES IN AMERICAN
POLITICS.
YOU CAN HAVE A DEMOCRACY,
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES SECRETLY
WORK TO CONTROL OUTCOME,
TYRANNY, OF COURSE, NO DECENT
PERSON SHOULD WANT THAT.
REPUBLICANS, DEMOCRATS, RATHER
WELCOMING SCRUTINY AND
TRANSPARENCY, SUNLIGHT,
RESPONDING WITH PANIC.
WATCH THIS.
>> TODAY WE HAVE THE FIRST OF
MANY DEMANDS ON DISPLAY.
OPEN ENDED INVESTIGATION INTO
WHATEVER CONSPIRACY THEORIES
HEADLINING THE CHAMBER.
>> MR. SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO H1-12.
>> THIS IS ALL ABOUT DEEP STATE
NON SENSE.
>> LET'S CALL IT WHAT IT IS,
REPUBLICAN COMMITTEE TO OBSTRUCT
JUSTICE.
>> RUSSIA IS ONE OF OUR -- TO
UNDERMINE THAT IS GOING TO BE
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS.
>> THEY WILL USE THIS COMMITTEE
TO GIN UP FAKE INVESTIGATIONS
INTO NON-EXISTENT SCANDALS.
WE NEED TO CALL THIS THE TINFOIL
HAT COMMITTEE.
>> Tucker: THERE IS VERIFICATION
IF YOU ARE WONDERING IF THE
FEDERAL AGENCIES BEING USED TO
CHANGE POLITICAL OUTCOMES NOW WE
KNOW FOR SURE.
IF YOU ARE A GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL
AND PANICKED AT THE IDEA WHAT
YOU ARE DOING WILL BECOME
PUBLIC, YOU ARE DOING SOMETHING
WRONG BY DEFINITION.
NOT JUST INTEL AGENCIES WHOSE
BEHAVIOR THEY WANT TO KEEP
SECRET.
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT YOU TO HAVE
ANY IDEA WHERE THE 100 BILLION
DOLLARS THEY SENT TO UKRAINE,
CONDI RICE, WHAT DID THEY DO
WITH THE MONEY?
JOE BIDEN ANNOUNCED WE ARE GOING
TO SEND MILLIONS MORE.
>> WE ARE GOING TO INCREASE
SUPPORTED FOR UKRAINE.
WE ARE GOING TO PROVIDE BRADLEY
INFANTRY FIGHTING VEHICLES TO
UKRAINIANS AND GERMANS WILL
PROVIDE VEHICLES THEY HAVE TO
UKRAINIANS.
WE ARE GOING HELP UKRAINE,
GERMANY ALSO ANNOUNCED TODAY IT
IS GOING TO PROVIDE UKRAINIANS A
-- TO DEAL WITH AIR ATTACKS
PATRIOT AIR DEFENSE SYSTEM.
WE ARE GOING TO PROVIDE
N
ADDITIONAL AIR DEFENSE BATTERY.
>> Tucker: THIS IS CRAZY.
THERE IS ACTUALLY A REASON FOR
IT.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING VERY RICH
FROM THIS.
THAT IS WHY WASHINGTON SUPPORTS
IT.
VERY SOON WERE GOING TO GIVE YOU
A CASE STUDY WHO IS GETTING
RICH.
SOME OF THE PEOPLE PROMOTING
THIS WAR KILLING ENDLESS NUMBER
OF UKRAINIANS AND YOU SHOULD
KNOW THIS.
SENDING SO MUCH MILITARY
EQUIPMENT TO ZELENSKY AND HIS
WIFE.
IF THE CONFLICT GOES ON ANOTHER
SIX MONTHS OR YEAR, CONTINUES TO
STRESS SUPPLY CHAIN IN WAYS THAT
ARE CHALLENGING.
YOU CAN EITHER DEFEND UKRAINE'S
BORDERS OR UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
WHICH IS IT?
MOST ARE CHOOSING UKRAINE.
IN THE HOUSE, THOMAS MASSY IN
KENTUCKY IS ONE OF THEM.
>> WE HAVE SPENT MORE IN
UKRAINE, U.S. CONGRESS THAN WE
HAVE SPENT MORE ON ROADS AND
BRIDGES IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
WE DON'T SPEND AS MUCH ON THAT
AS WE HAVE IN UKRAINE IN NINE
MONTHS.
I THINK THAT IS DESPICABLE.
PRIORITY
IES OUT OF .
WE ARE TRYING TO GET THE
DOCUMENTS TO FIND OUT WHERE THE
MONEY WENT.
WE NEED A FULL AUDIT.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A CRIME
AGAINST OUR COUNTR